tan
What are you doing ahhh
Are you ready for the stage?
I can't think of French history without
Hai-san But if you think of your talent,
Franchouche isn't suitable for i3 Don't
use love
as an excuse What about you?  Do you accept that you're only at that level
? That's what
you're saying.
This l-key
is my comrade-in-arms who has been fighting alongside me for a long time.
Turning common sense into defeat,
victory, and impossibility into miracles, I
've built up Kotaro Tatsumi, the producer of snow ---
[Music]
But until recently, I felt like I was really depressed,
so this electric key is yours.  Destroy the house that's always in your soul,
you made an excuse to give up on yourself who can't shine If there's something you want
, destroy everything and
take it away, even if it's a zombie  All about 9
let's use
this kind of jacker
[music]